it was in may of 1543 that it all
started
nobody remembers the exact day but i'm
thinking it might have been a wednesday
as the sun rose on that fateful morning
modern science was born
it was on this day that nicolas
comperticus published his opus de
revolutionibus erbium colestium or for
those of you whose latin is a bit rusty
on the revolutions of the heavenly
spheres
this book laid out mathematical
arguments for the heliocentric universe
and rejected geocentrism
in plain english he said that the sun
and not the earth was the center of the
universe
sadly copernicus died on may 24th of the
same year so he never saw his scientific
revolution unfold
it might be a bit early in this course
to indulge in anything
self-congratulatory but i'm going to do
so even so
the discipline of science has had a
bigger impact on humanity than any other
development
and i don't say that lightly as things
like philosophy religion and art have
all affected the lives of billions of
people
but science is the biggest
some important advances were made even
before modern science was developed
things like the taming of fire
metallurgy animal husbandry and
shipbuilding
but modern science greatly accelerated
our progress
over the last five centuries we have
learned to exploit electricity and
magnetism
understood the germ theory of diseases
and even harnessed the power hidden
inside the nucleus of atoms
chemists have created substances that
have vastly simplified our lives
we can treat cancer and vaccinate our
children so they live past infancy
science is truly incredible
science can also be intimidating what
with all those facts and figures and
equations and whatnot
for that reason many people leave
science to the scientists
people like well me for example i'm a
scientist a physicist to be precise and
i've spent years immersing myself in all
sorts of fascinating corners of the
natural world
it's been great fun by the way and if
you're a young person thinking about
your career i strongly recommend it
you will spend your entire life in a
constant state of wonder and your days
will be as full as you uncover the laws
of nature i've never regretted it that's
my tip for the day
most people don't dig that deeply into
science instead
they learn what they're taught in school
in science class
most of you viewing this course benefit
from having lived in a society that
values an educated populace
so you sat through classes learning
about louis xiv gerunds prime numbers
and yes science and of course that's
what this course is all about
i want to talk you about the science you
learned when you were younger
so just how good was that science
education on the whole i'm sure that it
was very good i really must tip my hat
to the hard-working science teachers out
there they're able to convey a great
deal of information on a vast range of
scientific topics things like biology
geology astronomy chemistry and physics
which is of course my personal favorite
they taught you tons of stuff however in
teaching such a huge array of subjects
compromises must be made
teachers had to teach things that
weren't really wrong but were only a
piece of the fuller story
you might have learned about the ideal
gas law in chemistry and it's a good
approximation but it's not completely
accurate
it works on only special cases and not
in all of them
maybe you learned about the bernoulli
equation and how it explains how planes
fly and there's merit to the way it's
usually taught but it clearly isn't the
whole story
for instance it doesn't explain how
planes can fly upside down
and then there's einstein's special
theory of relativity which tells us that
we can't go faster than light well that
part is true however those same lectures
will sometimes tell you that the reason
that you can't go faster than light is
because an object's mass increases as
you go faster and that i'm afraid to say
is totally wrong it's just not what
happens
so that's what this course is all about
as you watch the 24 lectures that will
be together i'll talk about common
misconceptions of science and i'm not
talking about the misconceptions of
youth like being told that the reason
that we have seasons is because the
earth is variously closer and further
from the sun
i'm talking about misconceptions that
are taught in fairly advanced classes
and are often believed by people with a
quite respectable scientific education
i'm talking about ways in which you
might have been taught wrong
now before we dive into the course i
want to make it clear that i'm not
criticizing your teachers
teachers have to make decisions on how
they present the material and sometimes
telling a partial truth is a way to get
across the big idea
for instance i have personally taught
people that whole mass increases as you
go faster thing as a way to convince
students that you can't go faster than
light
so i'm not blameless myself
sometimes a small misconception can
facilitate a much bigger truth that's
just the nature of education
okay so let me tell you how i will lay
out these lectures to begin with this is
a broad survey course and i can't assume
that you'll have prior knowledge of all
of the subject matter we'll cover
i mean it may well be that you
personally or science whiz but there may
be some subjects where your memory is
kind of fuzzy so what i intend to do is
begin each 30-minute lecture with a very
fast lesson in a way that highlights how
the misconception is commonly taught
and i'll point out the misconception
that i intended to spell that way you
can appreciate the meat of each lecture
with equal appreciation or well at least
i hope so
there are two subjects for which i'll do
things a little differently and those
are quantum mechanics and einstein's
theory of special relativity
those two subjects are incredibly cool
and mind-bending and are just utterly
chock-a-block full of misconceptions
however since they are mind-bending i
will devote an hour two lectures to each
of them with more introductory
explanations in fact it will be
difficult to cover either of those
topics in an hour although i'll cover
the high points
and if you find that you're interested
in the subjects well then the great
courses company has courses on both of
those subjects not by me but fascinating
courses nonetheless
so that's the plan each lecture will
have a short review of the subject
followed by me pointing out the
misconception and then the real story
sounds like fun right
let's begin
[Music]
now before we talk about specific
scientific facts i would be remiss if i
didn't talk about science itself
so just what is science well that
depends a lot on who you ask
many people would say that science is a
collection of facts things like the
earth is four and a half billion years
old or the egyptian pyramids were made
by aliens using ufos
that last one isn't real by the way but
it does lead us to the core essence of
what science is
science isn't so much a series of facts
but rather a way of observing the world
and generating testable hypotheses
those hypotheses can be confirmed like
the age of the earth or they can be
falsified like the whole ufo pyramid
connection
once the hypotheses are confirmed they
can be taken as facts
but facts in science can be soft things
they're not facts like saying that
george washington was the first
president of the united states they're
more malleable like newton's law of
gravity which is still a good enough
scientific theory that we can use it to
calculate orbital parameters and rocket
trajectories and accurately send a probe
to pluto
but when newton's theory of gravity was
proven to be incomplete it was replaced
by einstein's theory of general
relativity
scientific facts and ideas can change as
new information comes in
that way of thinking about facts is
discomforting to some who want an
unchanging worldview but it's the
flexibility of science that gives it
such power
ideas work as long as they work and to a
needed level of accuracy but they can be
discarded when new information comes in
or a higher level of accuracy is needed
but facts themselves aren't science
either science certainly does include
determining facts but it also includes
seeing how those facts can be woven
together into a tapestry that tells a
bigger story
it's about understanding cause and
effect and distinguishing those two
things from simple correlation
correlation is simply a fancy term for
saying that two things happen together
but as the saying goes correlation isn't
causation which means that just because
two things happen together doesn't mean
that one causes the other for instance
my secretary gets to work a couple of
hours earlier than i do now that's not
because i'm a bum she gets to work at 5
a.m every day she's a crazy early bird i
roll in at about 7 30. those two events
happen pretty much every day
so someone could observe those events
and conclude that her arriving at work
causes me to appear
that would be a credible hypothesis
but of course her arrival doesn't cause
me to show up
we both are governed by a bigger process
which is the start of the work day
our arrival doesn't depend on each other
our arrival depends on a larger truth
and this sort of thing is true in
science
if you live in the right part of the
country you'll see geese flying south in
the fall and a few months later it will
begin to snow
it's not that the geese somehow keep the
snow away but rather both phenomena can
be explained by the orbit of our planet
which is governed by the law of gravity
in some historical accidents which
determined the tilt of the earth
so science is a really big thing it's
built on facts sure but it's also a
methodology for determining and
accepting or rejecting those facts it's
a process for fitting those facts into
some sort of interconnected whole which
in turn results in a big picture a view
of the way nature works it's an
extremely powerful tool
and inherent in science is a perpetual
level of uncertainty and ignorance
science has to be prepared to change and
grow
before about the 1930s the idea of
galaxies was foreign to us the location
of stars in the sky seemed to be mostly
uniform except for the milky way or what
the finnish people once called linen
rada or the way of the birds
the milky way is a stripe in the night
sky that is brighter than the other
parts
the familiar name comes from greek
mythology when the goddess hera was
suckling the demigod heracles and a few
drops of milk were spilled and
consequently spread across the sky
the real reason for that brighter patch
of sky is of course because the milky
way is a galaxy and we're looking at it
edgewise and there are more stars there
by the way the linen rotted term
originates because the ancient finns
thought the earth was flat and the edge
of the earth was where the birds flew in
the winter
according to the legend they followed
the milky way to get there hence the
name way of the birds
so there are a couple of lessons there
both the greeks and the finns and other
ancient people had ideas that were wrong
and needed to be changed as more data
came in
of course both those mythological ideas
were discarded centuries ago and
replaced with the idea of star spread
mostly uniformly through the heavens
but the galaxy idea wasn't really
embraced until the 1930s when powerful
new telescopes showed a very different
picture of the universe
and that perhaps is the key point new
data means that our scientific picture
of the world will change
and if new data will change our picture
then that picture isn't the core of
science science is more about the
process it's about learning and
understanding and synthesizing and
revising and repeating the process over
and over again
incrementally better understanding the
world around us
for those who find comfort in unchanging
truths
science isn't the place to look
now this isn't to say that science is
all smoke and mirrors and opinions there
are things that we know that won't
likely change gravity pulls things
downwards
improved sanitation reduces diseases and
planes really do fly those things will
be true forever
so i don't want to oversell the
uncertainty bit just realize that a good
scientist must be constantly open to new
data and be willing to change his or her
views when new observations are
encountered so that's our quick preview
of the course and the nature of science
now let's get down to business
[Music]
the first order of business is to talk
about the scientific method itself and
where the ways in which it is normally
taught deviates from how it's actually
practiced
most people encounter a description of
the scientific method in elementary
school or middle school at the latest
that introductory description is based
on a recursive method which one might
describe in the following way
someone starts with an observation of a
phenomena say they see bumble bees
landing on flowers from this they form a
hypothesis which is that flowers are a
source of food for bees
a hypothesis is
described as an educated guess
the person then does experiments which
test the idea if the experiment fails to
support the hypothesis you reject it
if it succeeds then you can elevate your
hypothesis to the level of a theory
which we might call a tested hypothesis
finally if you test the theory over and
over again it always is supported by the
data you finally elevate your idea to
being a law which is the highest status
you could have in science
examples of that are newton's law of
gravity or ohm's law which describes how
materials resist the flow of electrical
current
you've almost certainly seen some
version of this description it's found
in essentially every textbook for young
children it's nice and simple and linear
with a leading to b leading to c easy
right
except that it's not
scientific research is never that simple
i wish it were it would make my life a
whole lot easier but it's not
the process is considerably messier with
far more twists and turns and revisions
and surprises there are dead ends and
false alleys and puzzled looks science
is way more interesting
and let's talk about the terminology
because that causes us no end of
difficulty
i use the word hypothesis to mean an
informed guess
theory to mean a tested guess and law to
mean a well-tested guess
now it's not that those words are so bad
but they have problems and that's
because words are slippery and tricky
things
they have multiple meanings
of course it's not a problem when words
have multiple meanings that's just the
nature of language
but the problem arises when a speaker
uses one meaning and a listener uses
another this problem can be especially
bad when the two meanings are similar
but subtly different
probably the least troublesome of the
scientific terms we're discussing is
hypothesis
pretty much everyone uses the term to
mean an educated guess or a motivated
explanation for something it's used to
describe a fuzzy level of knowledge
there is a much bigger problem when we
talk about the word theory
theory in the sense of our middle school
description of the scientific method
means a tested hypothesis which means
something that is pretty well supported
but for a lot of people theory is a much
dodgier term it implies a very poorly
supported idea i mean it doesn't take
much creativity to imagine two people
arguing and one of them saying to the
other one so what's your theory and you
can even hear the tone of the voice
which conveys a sort of dismissal of the
ideas not being worthy of even
consideration
this would already be a problem but
scientists use the word in a different
way
for us the term theory is more along the
lines of what basic scientific method
means when the word law is used i mean
let's think about some of the frequently
used terms and just how confident the
scientific community is on that topic
the theory of evolution
no serious scientist questions it what
about the germ theory of disease
putting aside the imprecise nature of
the word germ this is considered a
scientific fact microorganisms do indeed
cause disease
how about einstein's theory of general
relativity there's no credible debate
over this idea the gps on your phone
wouldn't work if we didn't take
relativity into account
so this is a tremendous communication
problem scientists sometimes use the
word theory in the sense a middle school
science teacher means it
but they just as often mean it to imply
a very well established scientific fact
and what about the term law well that
term is fallen out of favor
most scientists don't use the term
except in a historical context for
instance there is newton's law of
gravity and the law of conservation of
mass and chemistry
newton's law was developed in the mid to
late 1600s while the law of conservation
of mass originated in the 1700s
the term law was often used in the 1800s
in electricity like coulomb's law which
describes the force between two
electrically charged particles or
ampere's law which describes how
magnetic fields and electrical currents
are connected
the term law in this context originated
in the 17th century and stuck around for
a few hundred years before falling into
disuse among practicing scientists
to give you a sense of how true that is
remember that both newton's law of
gravity and the law of conservation of
mass were both demonstrated to fail at
high energies and strong gravitational
fields
what might you ask replaced it for both
cases it is einstein's theory of
relativity
an idea that we now label a theory is a
superior description of nature than an
older version that we label a law
it's no wonder that non-scientists are
sometimes confused
it's probably worth defining another
term that you might not have heard in a
scientific context and that word is
model
model is used a lot these days there's
the standard model which is near and
dear to my own heart and describes the
subatomic world but other scientists
talk about modeling the climate or the
weather there are lots of other examples
the term model is one that tries to more
clearly delineate this distinction
between the natural world and the ideas
we use to describe it for instance a
hurricane is a hurricane winds blow and
buildings topple the hurricane might hit
the florida coast and cross into the
gulf of mexico or it might turn
northward and travel along the atlantic
seaboard the hurricane is the reality
however atmospheric scientists try to
predict things before they happen like
the hurricane's intensity and path
they do that not by waiting until it
happens but by taking what they know
about the motion of the wind and the
transfer of heat from the ocean into the
atmosphere and then describe it using
complex mathematical equations
those equations are then put into a
computer and solved using numerical
methods to predict things that are
important to save lives and property
thus a model is kind of like a theory
although the word model often implies a
more calculational aspect than an
explanatory one
that's kind of a vague distinction and
don't take it too seriously but broadly
speaking if the goal is to make
calculations scientists more often use
the word model while if the outcome is
something that shows an elegant
mathematical encapsulation of an
underlying truth of nature the term we
usually use is theory
but the distinction is imperfect and not
uniformly followed so be aware that this
is a bit of a sloppy business
so
if we can dispense with a simplified
description of the scientific method you
encountered as a child how is science
really done
well to begin with there are more loops
and modifications
for instance the hypothesis generation
phase doesn't just come from
observations it can come from that but
it also comes from talking to others
reading the literature exploring what's
known and what's not
these all form an intricate interplay
then when you start to take data you
should have predictions with which you
can compare your observations
the data isn't usually cut and dried not
like you have a theory of gravity that
says that things hover above the ground
which you can prove false by dropping a
ball
most data aren't conclusive they might
support or contradict your idea you
might observe something wholly
unexpected or the data might prove
inclusive
or they might partially support your
idea which then causes you to modify
your hypothesis or change your
experiment
even once you've done your experiment
you need to see if others can replicate
it you need to have others criticize it
i mean even the best scientists can fool
themselves they can make mistakes they
can overlook things if you want your
idea to be bulletproof you need to have
everything vetted by the most critical
process possible if you have a thin skin
you shouldn't be a scientist because
it's a world of constant and brutal
critique
mind you it's not that your colleagues
are being mean on the contrary they're
trying to help
the goal of science isn't to win an
argument it's to be right and being
right means answering all questions if
you can do that you might be on to
something
if you're a person who plays on the
internet reading discussions on blogs
and bulletin boards you've no doubt
encountered arguments of the merits of
philosophy and how it's somehow a pure
discipline than science
or maybe you encountered this during
college discussions fueled by the
presence of an adult beverage or for
and this is an old conversation after
all long before the word scientist was
coined in 1833 by british philosopher
william welwell
the term used for those who studied
science was natural philosopher implying
that they learned about the philosophy
of the natural world
in fact the story of how the term was
coined is very revealing
well
first used it anonymously in his 1834
review of mary somerville's on the
connection of physical sciences
wellwell used the term satirically as
something of a complaint for the
proliferation of terms used to describe
scholars for instance chemist
mathematician naturalist where the term
philosopher was once used to mean those
who studied all knowledge
in an analogy of how the word artist
implied a practitioner of art a
scientist would be one who pursued
science
webwell also coined the term physicist
as one who studies
physics
there are those in the philosophical
community who regard philosophy as the
queen of intellectual disciplines from
which all the others are originated and
there's some historical merit in that
position
however some then imply that
philosophers are somehow superior to
other pursuers of knowledge
i see it differently i see it more in
the matter of evolution for instance it
appears true that the original form of
semi-complex animal was a sea sponge
over millions of years other forms of
animals evolved including the phylum
chordata which includes mammals and of
course us
and even though our ancestral organism
might have been a sponge that doesn't
mean that modern sponges can do calculus
it's more of a schism that occurred
early on and the divergences have made
the two organisms very different
in the same way philosophy allowed
science to arise but the two disciplines
are now quite distinct and science is
the more interesting of the two just
saying
academic trash talking aside there are
two core ideas of philosophy which you
must be aware to understand science and
i won't describe them rigorously here if
you're interested the teaching company
has many relevant courses in philosophy
but it's important to be aware of these
two metaphysics and epistemology
metaphysics is just the study of
existence
it might very broadly speaking be
described as being concerned with two
questions which are what exists and what
is it like
metaphysics is recognizably related to
physics but there are some very deep
questions one might ask about existence
for instance we could ask whether
there's an objective reality that exists
without us
that's like the question if a tree falls
in a forest and there's nobody there
does it make a sound and of course most
scientists would say yes if by sound you
mean vibrations of air that are at least
in principle hearable
other philosophers say that there is no
reality other than what exists in our
perception
this implies that the existence is in
the perceiving and that leads to
questions like whether you see red the
same way i do
obviously we can't know the answer to
that in detail which means that the
conversation will continue however
scientists have made a choice in this
debate
we would come down firmly on the
position that there is a reality out
there and that would continue to exist
even if we didn't
now this brings us to the second term
epistemology which might be called the
philosophy of knowledge it is concerned
with such questions of whether we can
know anything for sure and what it means
to rationally believe in something and
this is an important consideration for
scientists because we build our theories
and models on the basis of observations
if our observations are somehow flawed
then our theories will also be flawed
and this is very important it could mean
that at the very deepest and most
philosophical level we can never be sure
of our science i mean imagine for the
moment that you're being held in a giant
vat with all of your sensory information
fed to you kind of like in the movie the
matrix
then you wouldn't actually know anything
at all in fact our science would be
totally wrong the matrix is a good movie
by the way and it raises some
philosophical topics relevant to
scientists
now this doesn't stop us in our quest
for what science is we can move on and
make great progress in our understanding
of the universe but it's important to
realize that we're actually taking a
leap of faith and this faith involves
believing that our senses are a mostly
accurate representation of reality and
that there's no evil demon or laboratory
master that's deceiving us personally
i'm i'm pretty comfortable with that
i would like to take a moment to address
those who then say that science is like
religion because it rests on faith
no i i completely disagree faith is a
far more integral component of religion
but it's important for those of us who
really want to scientifically understand
the universe to be honest and understand
the fundamental limitations and
weaknesses of our discipline
for the rest of this course i'm not
going to return to this question about
whether the world really exists or not
i'm going to assume that it does i mean
if you can't assume that then you can't
do anything you might as well not even
get out of bed this morning that is if
you're even in a bed
spooky huh
but if we do assume that there is an
objective reality and that our senses
are a good approximation of the world
around us there is the question of what
science can prove can the scientific
method prove that a theory is true
well there's another important aspect of
science that takes some getting used to
and that's the idea that science doesn't
actually prove anything is true
that might seem weird given what you
think about science science is always
telling you things are true it tells you
the sun will come up tomorrow it tells
you that sugar will rot your teeth it
tells you that the universe was caused
in a ginormous explosion called the big
bang and all of those things are true or
at least true enough
the idea that science cannot prove
things to be true originated most
famously in the fertile mind of austrian
philosopher carl popper
popper was one of the most influential
philosophers of science in the 20th
century and he wrote extensively on
scientific epistemology
it was his contention that the
scientific method could not prove that
something was true
this is because one could have a
scientific theory that's right for the
wrong reason
to illustrate that idea think about the
explanation of the rising and setting of
the sun that was held in greek mythology
every day the greek titan helios drove
this flaming chariot across the sky they
rise and set rise and set day after day
a greek scientist could predict the
rising and setting of the sun using this
theory and according to the scientific
method he'd be justified in believing it
after all it made correct predictions
the theory might also predict that if
you looked at the sun with a suitable
telescope you'd see the titan and the
chariot however that prediction wouldn't
be observed and from that you could
disprove greek mythology
in modern days we say that the rising of
the sun is due to the spinning of the
earth and we're comfortable with this
idea however if tomorrow the sun didn't
rise we'd have to modify our theory
perhaps the sun stopped burning or
aliens caused the earth to stop spinning
perhaps it would be a glitch in the
matrix i don't know what but no matter
the reason we have to change our theory
then too
we can think of more realistic examples
like newton's law of gravity which
worked very well for hundreds of years
of observations but was replaced by
einstein's theory of general relativity
when newton's theory couldn't reproduce
measurements of the movements of mercury
this is popper's core idea which is that
scientific theories can't be proven only
disproven essentially the highest status
a scientific theory can have is not dead
yet now does this invalidate the
scientific method no of course it
doesn't but it reminds us of a very
important point which is to say that
science is a method more than it's a
body of knowledge the scientific method
generates the body of knowledge it gives
us a model of how the world works
but the result isn't static things can
change indeed things are guaranteed to
change our understanding is always
incomplete
so that's what science is it's a
glorious and powerful intellectual
endeavor it teaches us truths but we
must always be open to a newer and
better understanding and this brings us
full circle back to the point of this
course and the remaining lectures will
learn about newer and better and more
correct ways to understand things than
the ones that you were once taught
it's going to be great fun
[Music]
you